hey this is really funny uh just a
little bit of a break from the horrible
news you might enjoy this
a bunch of people in the audience have
been writing to me saying david you
should make an account on cameo
okay where people can sign up to have me
send people a shout out or troll
somebody i got a bunch of father's day
requests from people saying hey please
send a shout out to my dad or whoever
else
they really like the show this is all at
cameo dot com slash david pakman or you
just search my name in the cameo app
i got an absolutely hilarious request
from someone whose friend
i guess bought one of these online
charisma classes
and paid six hundred dollars and his
friend was concerned
so here's the here's the message that i
sent him take a look at this
hey matt so i heard from casey that you
spent
600 on an online charisma class
now maybe you're very wealthy and if
that's the case
that's fine but in my experience
you can find a lot of that material for
free
and i would even be glad for you to call
into my show
when i'm taking live calls and
talk about what i'm told is maybe a
desire
to uh improve some dating skills
okay so with total peace and love if you
want to figure out
a way to get on my show um you can
email me through my website we'll figure
out your phone number so that we take
live calls
if i see your number pop up we can talk
about what's going on it's free
no six hundred dollars for an online
charisma class
and hopefully hopefully you'll come away
with something
just as valuable okay so i want to hear
from you so i'm serious
i actually want to hear from matt i hope
that he will call in
i didn't realize that people actually
paid for online charisma
classes i guess i should have realized
that that because they've been around
for a while
someone must be paying for them but i
would love to have matt call into the
show
we can talk about what's going on but
maybe the funniest part about this
is that someone thought that i would be
the right person to go to for advice
on charisma and maybe dating
which i don't know something about that
is actually even funnier
so uh now also i've gotten some requests
on cameo that i had to turn down people
trying to get me to say
you know anti-semitic stuff and all of
this other stuff so so uh
some are being turned down but it's a
pretty fun platform you can send me
requests in the app
i am david pakman on cameo or you can
find me at
cameo.com davidpakman